hello alexandra andrea you can hear me
still right yeah we can hear you very
well well
are you ready for the match i was born
ready
i'm looking forward to it so we were
thinking
maybe we could do three plus two
adoption match since we're like
21 22 and you're 26. sure that works for
me
um and we were thinking it could be
maybe a little bit fun to put something
mild on the line
uh what what do you think about that
that's fine with me when you say mild
that doesn't involve like shaving
no no or eyebrows or whatever okay oh
roses
no that's the best for ourselves don't
worry we wouldn't put you under that
degeneration
absolutely not absolutely not um
unless no
hate cutting today do you want to play
for
for subs yeah that's good with me
okay do you want to do maybe 20 subs 10
subs
sure um how about how about 25
oh raising the stakes oh you're you're
looking to
uh raise the stakes yeah sure let's do
25
sounds good cool um so three plus two
if we get even one draw we win make
sense
okay so i'll take this seriously so so
no odds just um
straight up just straight up adoption is
it is it okay if we play three plus
three by any chance just so we can talk
but it's not
that's completely fine three three is
three three should be
completely fine yeah
[Music]
okay let's do this damn black was
looking forward to starting a game with
with e4 okay we're gonna play i think
i'm playing london
i wonder can i trick them we'll play c5
because i know they like
like to play bishop f4 but
i'm trying to confuse him
this is one way to maybe try and avoid
london meanwhile i could play c3
it's still playable
play yeah now we have a reverse queen's
gambit
um usually it's white moving the scene
pawn early but now
i'm the one moving the c pawn
it's still really solid for white but um
getting the early time advantage
can't complain too much g3 it's like a
reverse
what is this catalon
type thing i think i'll just develop
normally
it's playable it's funny they're kind of
combining
combining like a reverse queen's gambit
declined and
now a queen's gambit accepted
i don't even know what we call this but
i think they're just trying to confuse
me
or maybe we're both confused
yeah they're muted so if you want to
hear their commentary
you can you can watch through the squad
stream or you can open their stream in
the new
new tab um
but if i had their sound on it could
probably be too distracting
so i think i just want to play solely
here
maybe even
this move to start just maintaining a
nice
solid center um
that's a reasonable move i'll play this
just preventing b4
on this move threatening e4
and actually one of the points of
playing this and then back is now
queen d7 will come with tempo karpov
used to do this a lot
nice way to gain a little bit of time
okay i probably want to play e4
eventually
because the knight doesn't currently
have the square i'm expecting rook
d1 rook d1 queen c8
are you just getting off the the file
oh okay so now this move the knight has
to retreat
oh goo goo congrats on becoming a baby
pedor
yeah b3 is very reasonable um
i don't think i want to play this
because it allows this maneuver
so maybe i'll just keep developing i'll
put the rook here
i'll try and oh they just gifted me a
pawn
let's go okay
i was expecting king h2 uh it's usually
the the move to play to keep things
defended
okay
trying to start off solidly and uh
not blunder anything too early
actually i don't think they'll take
because i get a very kind of quick
mating attack
um it's probably best here for white to
play rook d1
and then hits the bishop and the pawn
if i play this i get forked it's
actually a good move
wondering if i can play this move
i still have some issues there
wait knight a4 is actually a really good
move i might not be like so much better
here
because here there's this move
here there's takes
takes etc
okay i think i'll just move all the way
back
keeping the tension i'm going to lose
the pawn i'll probably
trade and get the knight to e4
i want to lose this first game let's
take a 94.
my position is getting a little bit
tricky
i don't think that was their whole
master plan was to like sack the pawn
and then
have this knight a4 move but that may
have been one of the best approaches for
whites
so there's an idea here i think i'll
start by taking
and then queen c6 getting off the d file
lining with the king
some idea of playing b5 eventually
because the knight might get pushed back
to b2
i also have some idea of playing d4 just
unleashing the queen
get some x-ray vision
another idea is knight g5 queen here and
then queen h3
knight g5 would also threaten d4
love sign love sign love sign oh i love
you too
all hail the afasam thanks for that
wait can you people can hear me okay i
hope
um okay uh let's play this move
yes now i'm threatening this to hit this
and turn that
also e3 is a bit more vulnerable
i think f6 might just win a piece
because the bishop's tied down to the
knight if here i take and then take the
knight
let's go i i do see their reaction but
um i
probably yeah i probably just want to
focus on the position
uh let's play
oh they just resigned okay let's go
yeah with increment it's it's hard to
come back like no
no dirty flagging that was nice starts
kind of reverse kind of queen's gambit
type position oh there's free rook oh i
didn't see that
i just wanted to pressure the c pawn
okay
there was a free rook it's nice i
resigned though
something similar happened the other day
i played nemo
i was about to blunder my queen and
before i could blunder my queen she just
resigned
oh wait what oh she resigned and i would
have blundered my queen
like my philosophy is when in doubt
don't resign
there's always the hope the opponent
gets careless and sometimes it's easiest
to get careless when you
have a really good position
it's like the people who win the lottery
like you
you have so much money and then it's
it's so easy just to throw it all away
just getting getting careless in
in life the reason
why c5 isn't so common in this position
is c4 is actually a nice response but
okay we move on i'm gonna play a um
e4 i'm expecting a french oh
we have sicilian oh we have the slime
frozen
play one of these
okay so we're going into some
interesting theory
i feel like i played this and played
this line against them before
where i make the night move somewhere
awkward i develop i enjoy life
um at the same time black has the bishop
pairs so
it's not completely over but
as far as i know this is a fun line for
white
the i think the battery move here is a6
after which i would play e5 and then
it could get really really messy
let's go but i'm happy to see this
i might repeat this line like if they
play g6 again i might play h4
so knight g8 knight g8 setting up for
the next game
but that's logical so d6 is coming
probably
i think i'll just keep developing
[Music]
d6i bishop f4
so i'm fully developed with the minor
pieces i'm castled the rooks are ready
to come in
black has one bishop developed but now a
knight developed
um i wonder can i take and then take
the thing is black and castle there but
then i have this move hitting the bishop
and threatening the fork
that was actually that was a nice
combination if i didn't have queen h4 i
think black would be
surviving but uh this looks
this looks pretty winning so i'm either
winning the bishop or
forking and then maybe promoting so life
is very good
yeah i think they just stumbled into uh
some kind of opening trap so that's 13
moves let's go
two down just have to take it one game
at a time
i'm tempted to play in england but let's
be
let's be proper
if i play this i'll play c5 again
ooh queen's gambit this is going to be
almost as good as a netflix series
but slightly different probably
so queen's gambit declined um there's a
move i like to play a6 here
it's a kind of a pet line um the idea is
to eventually take play b5 c5
um i'll castle first i'm actually
waiting for the bishop to develop
and then i take and then go for the
stuff
yeah because i gain a lot of time bishop
moves three times
this is one of the ways for white to
play
um i think i'll play 97 first
preparing c5
and even though white has one more
centered pawn than me
um and this is very solid development
very typical for queen's gambit declined
i think you timotron solving with prime
yeah the idea is queen b6 rook c8 rook
d8
opening like this it's all about kind of
the the piece harmony
making pieces happy
i basically want to align the rook with
the queen
queen moves here i align the other rook
so the white queen could potentially be
a target i might have this move
i probably should have considered that
but this bishop is such a nice piece i
probably don't
even want to trade that off to double
white's pawns
just keeping the pressure
but moves like this or this or this
always something i should consider
because they're they're pretty forcing
moves
um c4 is not not a great move here
because after bishop c2
then there's less pressure on on the
center
also i'm i have more time than i started
with
this is all pretty much opening
preparation so far
um and the nice thing is not only is it
opening preparation but it leads to a
middle game where the moves come
quite naturally so like after rook c8
another plan is knight f8 to g6
which i might play right away
i could also
um there's h6 here as well
let's start with h6
because they have to make some
commitment with the bishop
bishop f4 maybe knight d5
i'm just trying to annoy the bishop
and time is very nice i mean this is one
of the things
when it comes to blitz i think opening
preparation is
um it's a much bigger factor because it
can lead to the early time advantage
uh now if i take there's knight takes
so i'm calculating takes takes there's
this move
there's also f6 here
which make things makes things a little
bit messy
it's interesting though
okay i have to calculate this there's
queen d3
by that f8
the calculation is bishop f4 i take
pawn can't take as i win the thing if
takes takes takes i have e5 with a fork
there's knight e6 i take hitting the
other knight
i think i'll just do it it looks kind of
wrong
but also kind of right
oh just realizing there's some weird
like bishop c7 but knight always covers
c7
yeah queen d3
another fade just covering the square
also
having more scope along the d file now
yeah this battery is um it's scary
oh i forgot about that move
um it should still be okay i can take
with bishop
now there's some discovery potential
night before
and it's about to get really really
messy
let's do this
i mean time conservation is really
important
i think it's still good i still have a
lot of initiative
a lot of pressure from various
directions a2 is randomly
hanging
i'm kind of expecting takes takes queen
e2
and then the threat will be this
oh what to do
ah yeah i kind of saw that potentially
coming
um it's just a big train
am i better here i don't know
roxy probably i could take
this move first
it should be better because i have more
more pressure on the queen side
oh
that's a brave move
i'm calculating um so takes takes knight
f1
i think bishop c4 knight d2
and i win the a pawn at the very least
let's go for this
i mean 92 white's going to survive
king f2 by fork
yeah they're untangling in the pressure
the pawn
actually rook oh never mind
knight defends the bishop
i was going to say rook a2 it's sort of
hard to defend the pawn there's this
move
it's definitely the hardest fock game so
far
and lights can be very very tricky
this move
let's move first
but not on d4 defending the b pawn
and time is still good
now i can win this pawn defending yeah
winning upon defending upon
there's a cool tactic bishop here and
then takes takes
let's go that was nice
okay i was very tough position to play
in uh in time trouble
um yeah it was like a very solid
position
but uh it took a long time to make
progress
okay let's play i'll play another e4
if sicilian maybe i'll mix it up um i'm
expecting french yeah we're gonna play
an ortho schnapp
so i played botezbat who played queen h4
uh c6 is actually kind of a funny move
it's playable play this and this
we're transposing into um it's like the
martial gambit of the queen's gambit
bishop b4 is more common
also looks playable play this move
oh how crazy do i want to be thinking
bishop g5
no let's be let's be simple
so i'm allowing bishop here i just want
to get a very kind of stable
development not doing anything too fancy
early on
play this move just have to make a few
things
updated in chat it should be good
okay this is a very typical move um pawn
c5
for the structure
actually i think it'll stay flexible
rookie one
i might have ideas of d5
and what to do here so b3
queen e2
maybe h3 i'll play h3 first
ensuring that this is no longer a target
so very often these types of positions
black wants to eventually play
e5 or c5 um c5 can't be played right
away because knight b5
probably expecting like b6 yeah
very simple and solid so i'll play queen
queen e2
both completing development
trying to manage my time
pawn cube when someday in the future
e5 might be coming now
um c5 doesn't quite work
i'm tempted to
[Music]
play knight e4 it's actually very solid
position for black
okay let's try 94.
i don't want to burn too much time here
this interesting move
um c5 now
let's um let's optimize all the pieces
and g3 also possible bishop b1
just potentially going for the the
mating battery
i'm trying to not make like too many
commitments
so we go for the trade
and the plan is probably still a bishop
e1 queen here here etc
and knight f6 might come
yeah they're opening and kind of middle
game play it's very very solid in this
game
i guess that's a question if i want to
play like really aggressively like go
for the mating attack
or play position in the center like go
for c5
95 etc thank you andrew andrew
p buchanan solving with prime
se5 is probably going to come very soon
oh kings gambit i don't think they play
e4 e5
otherwise i would yeah i would have fun
with some gambits
that's a good move
okay we're going to get more kind of
positional game
it takes takes
i have slightly better structure
not entirely clear what the plan is he
takes in queen e5
losing a pawn this also takes
95
this bishop is very very strong always
have to watch out for mating ideas
yeah they just want to like simple mate
me
um so maybe f3
ugly looking move but playable
this is not good actually i'm knight g4
f5 could come this move
don't want to blunder anything
i just want to trade queens also f5 i
have 93
so maybe that's okay oh but then knight
h3
wait f5
f5 h4
it's getting really complicated
what
what okay they're just sacking trying to
destroy me
i think it's okay though
i'm so confused f5 is coming
no this is okay
better be okay
i thought i can take the rook take on e6
and then take on
f5
yeah there's a pin now okay i think i'm
in the clear
that was a very dangerous position i
think they they just mixed up the move
order they could have played that five
without sacking the knight
i was in big trouble there
finish things off in style oh okay
so resignation i was it's definitely the
toughest game
i feel like every game there they're
improving they're like they're learning
from their mistakes getting stronger
so that's four four wins
i'll be black next game maybe i'll play
i'll mix up the opening
play knife six on move one if they keep
playing d4
yeah let's go almost halfway there
obviously i want to play stafford i'm
kind of tempted to play in england
too like play that uh
the oman hamilton queen sack in england
um of course i want to go for as many
opening traps as possible
but i don't want to play anything that's
like that's
too too risky at least early on
go play a dutch uh
no not right now maybe
and if i get to like nine games i'll do
something fun
for the the final game oh london time
uh let's play this and this
also thank you dr r gifting
gifting a lot of subs thanks so much
gifting 10 subs
really appreciate that
okay so this is actually our first
london of the match
maybe next game i'll play a london
um just for fun
because i've been playing e4 every game
knight d2
okay let's continue
f5
it's like a different sort of move order
i want to go for this queen b6 line
i usually actually um a queen b3
immediately
so i can play queen b6 oh wait a minute
did i mess this up already there's queen
d7 here
queen d7
i hope i didn't mess this up some
eventual c4
it's sometimes risky putting the queen
here allowing
the knight to come to e5 but
um yeah white's a little bit too slow
because i'll play c4 next
also thank you to fretto also subbing
with prime
so i know i know there's like questions
comments in the chat but i'm
i'm trying to stay focused on these
games
um so i'm really trying not to look so
much a chat
during the actual games but probably
after the match i'll stick around
answer some questions let's play c4 here
attacking the queen the queen probably
moves all the way back unless it moves
to a4
if a4 a4 i might play a6b5
and now yeah 95 would lose uh
lose material so b4 interesting
i don't want to take because it just
gives white better structure
um well b4
played that really quickly too i might
just play e6 here
if b5 i i have 97 winning the pawn
oh why are clocks flashing
wait oh no what's going on
probably some server issues
probably server issues hopefully the
stream didn't die
it's always concerning when that happens
okay let's play bishop e7
castle
that's just another reason to keep a
time advantage
i don't want to like flag when the
server crashes yeah i think we're good
up about a minute um this is a very
pleasing structure like sometimes if you
can get this
where it's really solid uh white can't
play bishop d3 it's hard for white to
play
pawn e4 e4 is usually the main break
so they might go for like this and this
but then b5
i'm gonna go for like the positional
squeeze
or i'll just try and prevent all of
their plans
i played h6 um with intention of
uh afternoon h4 i have bishop h7
um
i honestly i'm not sure what to do here
so i'm just gonna play kind of
hopefully quick improving moves try and
make them burn more time
so i'm playing this hoping for bishop c2
after which b5
wins a piece oh i could play b5 right
away actually
because then the queen has to move here
i play a5
and bishop d1 deprive the queen of
of d1 okay knight e5 is now playable
have to take it or i still or no i
no not b5 i'll take it and play this
and probably ruxiate i'm expecting this
move
there's a funny line queen a5 rook c8
never mind
some potential bishop d8 so now a5
yeah this is really nice queen b2 i take
and i want to prepare c3
so maybe this move threatening c3
also preparing knight d7
i was about to play rook a4 which just
plunders a rook or an exchange
okay so knight c3 is coming
[Music]
i don't want to make life easy for them
i might just play kind of gradual
positional build up rook
a7 rook 8 i'm gonna try and put a rook
on a3
it's a respectable move or is it
maybe it's not i can take and take on b4
there we go
okay finally materials
if you say pretty please adjust it
during the game
okay i can take this way sorry about
that
maybe maybe people were were struggling
with which number was which
okay i guess life goes on here might as
well take and
bring the knight here
yeah no reason to go too crazy
just going to play solidly
i like very soon i want to start just
pushing the pawns
and they're trying to complicate things
but also blundering a bishop okay
let's go okay that was nice
so it is five five out of five
making progress um
i'll play a london yeah why not a user
opening against some
so we're following the first game ah
okay
i know they like to play king's indian
so we're going into some variation of
the pierce
which can be potentially really really
fun
eventual idea bishop here storm on the
king side
c5 so soon
so if i play this takes takes takes um
and c5 is making me think
most people castle in that position
maybe i'll i'll take first and then go
for e5
looks fun
yeah because uh the pawn is pinned so it
takes i just male and d8
and then that move
okay i pretty much have to take i'm
thinking about bishop b5 but i can do
that later
probably queen d5
just putting my queen
in their face basically yeah the queen
um
the queen attacks the knights i have
vision b5 ideas
i'm threatening d6 four different times
with various things
um oh
f2 hangs what f2 hangs
okay i guess this is turning into a
gambit
that was not intentional
oh that was really bad
why did i do that
try this move
that was really bad i have to resort to
tricks
okay so i need to take and then win the
rook maybe
yeah they have a lot of time to think
through this too
and the goal now is to make things
complicated
i just got way overconfident there that
was really bad
i just forgot about f2 sometimes when
you're in this mindset of like
trying to attack and make threats you
sometimes forget what the opponent wants
to do
okay so take i mean there's some
[Music]
compensation hopefully queen d7 might
happen
that's actually a really good move
so it takes takes like i have to win
this too
which could be problematic
oh no
i have to keep coins on the board
let's pawn count punk accounts equal so
it takes
trying to weigh my options i probably it
looks really bad but i'm probably gonna
have to trade queens
and keep the night
there's another interesting option to
trade and then actually take here
[Music]
takes takes or trade and play knight f3
i'll trade and play knight f3
okay
um i mean there's still hope but
uh this is not good if i take
lose b2 should play c3 here
oh if takes i take and there's potential
fork
okay there's still hope i think rook b8
was a slight inaccuracy because they
can't easily trade now
on e5 so i keep i'm going to keep both
minor pieces on the board
um down about a minute
yeah this is my worst position by far
in this match
like to play for a win like maybe i
could hold on for a draw but
i mean i think that the best hope is to
like set up some forks with the night
somehow nights can be tricky
or just keep pressuring the g6 pawn
like they forced me on too so i have to
somehow
return the the favor
i like the fact they're thinking
okay so let's take with so knight bishop
can't take
i'm also i'm hitting oh oh i'm setting
up some discovery
i didn't realize that i'm like any
knight move next move will
discover attack the rook with my bishop
huh so i have rookie one rookie one
looks really fancy
because again takes takes and now i'm
guaranteed to
win one of the rooks it's we still get
an end game it's equal
equal pawns um
but i mean this is the best i could hope
for
okay let's see
how i want to do this probably take the
least active rook
and the rook probably wants to be on a5
just to constantly pressure the pawn
that's a good move
it's going to be a fight of chief
the g pawn move can be interesting
um
probably not necessary i just want to
start pushing
takes don't have time to calculate
i want to play check and key five or
second
i want to play c4
position's looking better but it still
takes a lot of work
there's no g5 there's no e5 this rook is
so nice okay now i play c4
oh c4 was maybe a blunder because i
allow e5
i could find it's still
tricky okay i'll play this move so they
one connect four
uh throw in the check
how to do this
okay i'm gonna blockade with a king
oh gee
that was a good move
do you have this move it's getting
really weird
i want to play b6 probably
or b7 i play rook a7
king six i check and then make a queen
let's go
oh man this game this game was so
stressful they were so close
like even even before king e6 i don't
know maybe they had the chance to
keep playing on oh
okay sub t sub t
okay that was intense and that's why
like
after knight f2 i've had to just move on
with life except
the fact i blundered
um okay okay so that's six
i really have to be careful i was a
wake-up call
um
yeah i don't know like i i think king
king here if the king gets to c6 i don't
know what's happening
oh thank you people for the bits thank
you pie hole superior wood
zutun kamen i appreciate that
okay we have already yeah that whole
game was theory right
that game was probably like back on me
tie worthy
oh they're playing king's indian so i'll
play
i'll play this line i'll play something
really solid here
just recover
i have a feeling nerdsy probably showed
them this
or something like this knight takes
or pawn takes a pawn takes
c5 coming
yeah it's just um basically what i'm
doing it's a setup based opening
where i'll have something kind of
resembling
queen's gamut declined
that's a that's a solid move play this
in
probably not here rook here first i'm
not sure whether marinette wants to be
on c6 or d7
also thinks uh yeah i think still would
uh for the bits as well
um i think now knight c6 knight is well
placed usually against the queen on c2
some eventual knight b4 possibilities
i mean we're both really solid like
everything
is defended in white's position
everything defended my position
so if i play this there's queen b1
queen g7 knight f5 we trade queen f5
it's okay oh
okay i thought this was a mistake
because
of this move let's move first then i
take and then knight d3 will fork
there is bishop h3 here so or even
knight e5
but 95 i take and win the knights
so bishop h3
okay i don't have to calculate that um
yeah i guess i'm fortunate that i was
just hanging there
okay yeah it's nice winning material
early
rather than losing material early
uh okay but it's still oh e5 is actually
an idea
so life goes on
so probably queen d7 just defending the
bishop
being solid
oh there's a cool line e5 takes never
mind there's some like mating potential
so i'll play this move aligning with the
bishop on g2
because of e5 i just meet
okay i think they want to they want to
skewer me
or just control a square let's play
play this move
yeah positions like this when you're up
material uh yeah
i was gonna say they just require
patience um
okay that was nice
so what was the previous game let's
let's redeem myself
in that uh that london line because i'm
completely fine going for the same
variation
where i won't
oh they're they're playing something
different okay
oh the copycat variation
interesting
so there's two plans i can play here
either
c4 queen b3
or i'm gonna play the trickier line
knight e5
idea g4 and then h4
it's kind of a rare idea i don't think
it's objectively good they're just
copying me
what is this oh they're just copying me
can i play f3
f3 looks nice
f6 okay no the copying stops that's good
so now
yeah now g4 h4
and the bishop gets a little bit iffy
there is f6 and then i'll take
and um
yeah i think this is pleasant
and probably bishop g3 first bishop d3
etc
yeah this g pawn it's so nice having
light squared bishop here
when black doesn't have lights for
bishop hey thank you
atalkowski gifting to danny strikes
appreciate that f5 is a good move
some reason i was expecting king f7
so i mean everything's defended
i might just play c3 like be extra solid
oh they want to play bishop e7 oops
grab this move
um the g5 they just take
you have to play h5 here it's not the
original intention
but it still looks okay probably queen
e2
and then knight d2 and then castle etc
it's gonna be a fight though i'm not uh
wait was there a prediction what is the
prediction
i don't know what the prediction was a
lot of people saying yes or no in the
chat
um okay i should say focus though
probably 92 wait i'm almost driving the
bishop there's bishop h6
but then bishop h4 but then the queen
moves
they want to play f4 though
how to deal with this
queen f6 is a good move
i might man i might take on d6
f4 wait a minute f4 bishop g6
gets really weird
takes takes now i'm gonna play knight d2
worst case scenario never mind
my castle here sack upon f4 we trade
bishop h69 f3
doesn't look too bad i could play f4
right away actually
i'm too indecisive
[Music]
i gotta move quicker too
i think i'll start with this
it's risky
so i'm gonna beat down a pawn
oh this could have been really how are
they man they're moving really quickly
i thought i tricked them in the opening
okay now i'll play let's just keep
things simple i'll take and play this
move
so the idea is i trade off my bishop and
then put the these pawns on dark squares
so my bishop doesn't get stuck and then
there's no knight e4
this pawn's now defended
life should be better now
and then the rook will come to the g
g-file it's actually a really nice kind
of
positional bind because the knight's
restricted
bishop's restricted as well by my my
pawns
i'll have to be living on the increments
okay so some easy moves i guess knight
of three does allow
does a lot work h5 i guess it kind of
does
getting ready to double up
play queen f3 just preparing this
now it's getting weird
like they could play g6 here yeah that's
actually a good move
um let's play this and then this
the knight wants to come here here
what no mercy right
i feel i feel bad slightly confused but
i think they intended to play this
that's the nature with uh with
mouth slipping i guess i feel kind of
bad
but no mercy they played like a good
game up until that point too
they were going for this like positional
maneuver
did andre andrea just kind of rage walk
away
hopefully she'll come back okay
um oh she's back
okay yeah after something like that
sometimes you need to take a very brief
stroll
mentally recover yeah no mercy that
should be my
motto in life
i don't think it's even possible to
offer a take back
oh one minute okay sounds good
so we do have a small break
oh yeah i have to make a no mercy emote
for situations like this
so i'm um i'm 8 out of ten i need to win
two more to officially adopt
and secure
what is it pride glory 25 gifted subs
um the last time we had a match like
this
i won nine games and then the final game
ended in a draw
so that's sometimes one of my weaknesses
is when i
i'm in like a really good position
momentum's on my side and then
i kind of slip at the finish line so
we're gonna stay
mentally strong not gonna blunder or
mouse slip hopefully
um i might play i might mix it up with
this one when to or when not to play the
job over london compared to the standard
london
ah yeah i mean my rule is if they go for
this i play job london
go for e4 if they do anything else i
usually stick with
standard london so i hope that makes
sense
but you can mix it up like both are
playable against whatever black does
okay we'll play this move
we'll see if they go for queen's gamut
or london or
something else
okay let's play i'll stick with
the solid stuff they're playing queen's
gambit declined
exchange variation thank you the stephen
gray gifting five subs appreciate that
they're actually playing a very solid
setup here
so this could be kind of a long ish
grind
at the same time i basically have a
reverse london
but they're oh their bishops develop so
it's not quite the same thing
i'm trying to figure out how to play
aggressively here
i should probably just complete
development like a normal person
but this move this move looks fun bishop
here i'll play this
because there's some idea of knight e4
oh they hit me first with 95.
okay so we could trade
i'm not thrilled about this opening
actually actually maybe 94.
yeah we're both violating the same
principle like we're moving the same
piece twice
before like completing developments
but i'm trying to pressure various
things i'm threatening to take the
bishop
uh which is currently defending the
knights and then basically win a pawn
um and the idea yeah the idea here would
be to eventually get this move
so maybe start with bishop takes
pawn takes would kind of kill this
bishop
and now i am threatening this i'm
preventing the bishop from developing
because the g2 pawn would hang
a3 is logical
i'm looking for ways to just punish
white
for being slow but
i kind of want to play h5 actually
it might be wrong but it'll be fun
i just want to trap the bishop
and maybe eventually f6 g5
etc actually um one point is if white
plays h3 and then i play f6
and light moves i i take and damage the
structure
i am threatening to play this bishop f4
g5
so f3
i want to play h4 it gets messy
i think i'll do it though wait a minute
i'm calling here here
here queen g4
i probably don't want to deal with that
i play bishop about five
the queen g4 rook h2
it gets so messy
i think it's okay though
let's do it can't be wasting too much
time
so the calculation is takes takes queen
g4
rook h2 quincy a queen d it takes takes
i get kind of forked but after this
takes the rook would be hanging
if takes i almost promote um
i don't think white's damaging like even
if takes i can allow takes and just
promote
or win the rook and then when the other
rook
okay so we don't go into that so now
maybe i take
oh that was actually a good move
oh they're actually kind of solid here
maybe i should have been looking at this
move not the other line
[Music]
okay let's play bishop h7
so that after this my bishops defend
that i can play oh but then knight g6
for bishop g6
oh but i'm threatening to win a pawn
okay so they have to
do something about this
yeah i was more looking at bishop f5
bishop d3
bishop d3 not possible here
so knight d3 okay i mean we're playing
the opening very slowly like it's such a
weird
variation okay now maybe knight b6
or even b5
play this move okay i don't know which
way i should castle
so i've already committed h pawn green
side also looks a bit shaky
okay
and we're both getting low on time i
probably want to play knight c4
like target e3
they're kind of in the same spot like
it's not clear which way white wants to
castle because there's
potential attacks on both areas of the
board
i like the fact they're taking time you
just keep thinking for another 20
seconds
ooh fancy
okay um
maybe this move and b5
ah e4 is the plan
so that's actually a decent idea let's
play f5
i'm just going for the squeeze a good
move
h3
let's chill let's castle
yeah let's start moving quicker
now g5
okay staying solid
oh now i can take because of the pin
yeah if they took here it would have
been probably fine for white
okay pawns go marching
um no need to do anything too crazy
let's just play king here
for good measure
now we're both trying to find our bullet
mode let's keep pushing another pawn
ooh pin and win let's go pin and win
did i miss a fork i probably missed
knight d2 at some point
but i i found i found the pin
in the haystack okay
okay that's nine i'll be white next game
what do i play next game i want to do
something crazy
but not too not too crazy i don't know
maybe i'll play e3 maybe i'll go for
like reverse stafford or reverse england
uh i'm gonna play e3 and pre-move e4
next game
that's gonna be my secret opening prep
okay next game okay
let's go
let's go oh wait what they copied me
what is this
we both play the french what is this so
i'm just a french down the tempo
that's sad i'll play the one night
attack
against the french because i lost a
tempo
um
yeah i wanted to go crazy okay maybe
i'll
i'll play this and then
no i'm not gonna blonde cloud chad is
not
always the best influence but
maybe i'll i'll play i'll play like a
grand prix
i'll try and be aggressive in the middle
game
and this is serious i don't want to trip
at the finish line
um i do want to follow some basic
principles
like not bond clouding
like we need to preparing the
i'm probably not going to be a fork but
e5
is some idea
don't choke that's good life advice
it's hard to choke on t oh knight a4
queen a5
so sneaky if i play this move
okay so i'm going a little bit crazy
rather than moving my knight i'm
counter-attacking the
bishop um
so if takes takes oh there's a line
takes takes takes so i win the queen
that's reborn on a1
and then i'm just down a rook so that's
probably really bad for me
oh but takes wait takes takes
takes takes takes takes and then takes
and that's really good for me because i
would win a rook in that line
oh yeah they're going to win everything
um bond clouding is illegal so let's
castle
cool pawn formation
this pond's just chilling
it's like moses crossing the the red sea
pawns like parted ways it's not defended
it can't really move
forward without support
[Music]
i kind of want to play b3 here
kind of like a nice positional move
and then these pawns are completely
blockaded
and what i'll do is put the knight maybe
on c4
or maybe not i'll put them on e5
and then
yeah it's really hard for black to do
much on the the queen side
i mean the pawns are supported i guess
this pawn is not defended
i probably don't want to take it if i
take the pawn the diagonal opens for the
bishop
every so often i'll glance a chat and
just see terrible things
being recommended like d4 for content
no not right now probably never
bishop b7 yeah that's just the
saddest fiancee bishop
i think i'll play this move
i could wait what to do
let's play this move so i'm achieving
kind of my dream setup
the knight is supported defending the
pawn attacking the queen the queen
can't retreat this way it has to go to
one of these
sad squares and then i'll play bishop e7
this is such an epic squeeze like black
is almost in zuzwan
like this can't really move the queen
after a4 the queen will have no squares
the king can't castle either way
it's so beautiful and then maybe
maybe i'll just push the f pawn and main
on f7
oh they want to trade that's actually a
good plan so i'll put the knight back
and then yeah that's oh my bishop's
attacked
okay i got i got too carried away there
i thought i was just easy
winning but they have counter play i
don't want to lose like these are my
babies
bishop and pawn or like twins
[Music]
so i'm thinking wait
how to do this
f4 or rook
maybe you rook here oh the clocks are
flashing again
but only momentarily so the idea is to
take on f7 and then win e6 and then
eventually checkmate i am losing a2 but
i don't think this pawn is relevant
in this grand scheme of things
yeah now the pawn is
pawn is chilling on e7 keeping the king
company
preventing the king from casting either
way it's actually kind of a nice
nice spot
that's a good move because they they
prevent me from winning e6
in the end
play queen e3
so planning to either take this way or
just go this way defend the pawn
yeah no mercy
play this move
oh so now i'm threatening to take the
pawn trapping the rook
okay so that's a good move
um like they want to play this and this
queen queen here
hitting both pawns
they black actually can't defend both
pawns
because they're rook committed if here i
trapped the rook again
and this is a made in one threat
the is the pawn gonna survive for the
whole game
okay wow that was actually that was a
nice game
i i didn't give in to temptations of
what chat wanted me to do with like pawn
clouding or queen sacking
uh this nice kind of squeeze this pawn
this pawn went on a magnificent journey
i didn't lose a single pawn that game
my epong my epon transitioned to it
becoming a d-pawn
and then transitioned back to being an
epon
it's a circle of life
okay that was that was fun i um
i i hope they enjoyed that there's some
some stressful games
was that one like really crazy game
hello congratulations we had a really
bad day for our chess oh uh
yeah the game the games were actually
like super fun but
uh terrible no
don't don't lie to us this was the worst
you've probably ever seen us play ever
say the truth well some of the so
the early like that one game where you
you got knight f2 like i blundered and
then i had to really kind of try and
fight my
way back like the match could have just
ended if you i guess if you held on to
material the one where we were up the
exchange
yeah like i plundered really yeah that
one was really hard we didn't know
well if we didn't take your pawn uh we
didn't know what else we could have done
enough also i just saw i just saw the
sub bomb thanks so much
congratulations i did have to work hard
so to get that
yeah yeah we know we literally almost
tried to castle through checks so it's
just one of those days
yeah it was it was you know what i was
up late i did not
wake up properly this morning
i mean that's what coffee is for or tea
yeah you can make a but your openings
are so good so it's actually very cool
to see you know your theory so well and
it is
always very educational from you so
yeah i think like a few of the earlier
games i got you i
like i was being tricky in the opening
got you into some traps but
then like later on you adjusted so but
it's um
it's a nice kind of lesson going into
these tricky openings where you
you want to avoid certain traps yeah i
was really scared to play my london
against you
and dang right the one game where i did
i panicked
because you're the only person who knows
it so well yeah
at some point maybe i will have to have
like a london master class or
that i can share londoner preparations
yeah that would be yeah
the best thing ever but i i think that
would help us so that things like this
don't happen in the future
definitely well done eric you played
very well
i really appreciate it so thanks for
doing this we'll we'll challenge you to
a rematch once we've studied a little
bit more
yeah definitely yeah sounds good yeah
maybe
maybe i'll have to hold off on revealing
like all my preparation uh
yeah at some point you'll get revenge
but have that stream and then we can do
a rematch
exactly maybe i can prepare you for
myself which could be interesting
yes yes yeah i prepared against myself
yeah there we go i think that should
about equal the odds
yeah okay um that was fun
that's going on youtube for those
watching in the future
on youtube thanks for watching you can
watch live on twitch
click the link in the description